[Musique]
audition publique avec deux invités ce
soir d'abord sur les suite de l'échec de
l air aux européennes jean françois copé
bonsoir soi et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir avec nous également pour cette
première partie d'audition publique
brigitte boucher et oriane mancini
bonsoir mesdames
et puis sur les municipales un sujet
d'ailleurs qui est lié au premier avec
dans le casting parisien mais sans
étiquette gaspard grande soeur
il sera là avec nous donc dans une demi
heure maintenant avec paulo bria et avec
vincent roux jean françois copé je
rappelle que vous êtes
l'ancien président de l'ump après la
démission inévitable vais vous dire de
laurent wauquiez de la présidence des
républicains peut- il ya encore et selon
vous peut-il y avoir encore une
stratégie gagnante pour pour la droite
pour votre parti ou là comme vous y
allez passer la question
une stratégie gagnante on va déjà
essayer de stopper la désagrégation
et petit à petit centimètre carré par
centimètre carré essayer de reconquérir
un peu le coeur des français
voilà et toute autre considération à ce
stade me paraît prématuré
vous nous annoncez l'a vraiment un
travail de longue haleine
est-ce qu'on est obligé de mentir tout
le temps et de faire des envolées
lyriques qui évite de faire l'inventaire
des raisons pour lesquelles on se trouve
dans cette situation non je pense qu'il
est quand même grand temps de le faire
on a manqué ce rendez vous au lendemain
de la débâcle des présidentielles
puisque moi j'avais comme un certain
nombre d'autres de mes amis d'ailleurs
proposé qu' on retarde un tout petit peu
l'élection interne à l'époque pour
presser de faire une espèce d'inventaire
de la situation de réfléchir pour savoir
sur quoi on était d'accord c'était un
tonneau non il fallait absolument
laisser la place tout de suite alors
invoqué et ça a donné ce qu'on a vu bon
peut-être que là pour vous n'allez pas
des champs près parce que tu arrives à
personne n'est surpris un franchement
personne s'avoue plus toute personne qui
vous parle sérieusement vous dira qu'il
n'y avait hélas aucune surprise dans ce
processus infernal de désintégration lié
au fait que
les gens qui voulaient porter une idée
un peu différente était systématiquement
écartés que toute tentative de proposer
une stratégie un peu plus large et est
immédiatement arrêté et que le débat
n'existait plus blog c'était laurent
wauquiez non le problème c'était d'aller
au delà de ça la manière dont il a conçu
sa présidence peu importe maintenant
c'est fait mais le fait que nous avons
en fait nous sommes interdits de prendre
ce temps nécessaire pour comprendre ce
qui nous a amenés à vivre cette descente
aux enfers alors certains pour aller
vite évacué le débat disait c'est copé
fillon voilà alors ça c'est c'est eh oui
je ne vous en parle très librement
ok ou qu'on ait une autre part je non je
n'en disconviens pas mais ça ne saurait
à soi tout seul je rappelle que c'est
quand même une affaire qui date de 2012
à soi tout seul explique et les
désastres d'aujourd'hui les choses sont
plus complexes et je pense que c'est un
rendez-vous aussi de réflexion
intellectuelle qu'il faut qu'on est bon
c'est à dire que maintenant il ne faut
pas choisir un chef il faut d'abord
bâtir un projet re bâtir sur des idées
avant de saisir à chaque fois j'en sais
rien je pose des hypothèses
voilà je pense qu'il ya des moments et
c'est même moi qui vous le dis où il
faut essayer d'avancer avec un peu moins
de certitudes et un peu plus
d'interrogations
donc j'en mets quelques-unes sur la
table la première c'est que je ne sais
pas si l air est encore compte tout ce
qui s'est passé
la structure qui peut permettre de
puiser l'énergie suffisante pour y
arriver
voilà on s'est tellement rabougri 8%
c'est un étiage qui va moi qui suis
gaulliste porter depuis toujours d'une
approche majoritaire jme 18% je suis
même pas quoi ça ressemble donc ça c'est
la première chose qu'un être humain en
tout cas je dis que aujourd'hui cette
question il faut la poser se saborder
lyonnais non non vous avez un goût plus
vite
moi je dis pas ça après je dis je ne
suis pas sûr que tel quel il ne faille
pas réfléchir une transformation
profonde barça c'est le premier point
deuxième point j deuxième interrogation
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille ce
prévenu qu'il faille se précipiter dès
maintenant dans l'élection d'un nouveau
chef de ce parti alors qu'il ya des
statuts vous le devez le faire au moins
50 jours au plus tard en 60 heures
joueurs on arrive au mois de
alors complété de vu le contexte je dis
ça vaut peut-être la peine qu'on propose
lors d'un conseil national de modifier
un peu tout ça voilà deux peut-être
proposer un directoire
encore une fois je suis à ce stade dans
liszt à ses propositions pour les mettre
sur la table après peut-être qu'elles
sont mauvaises on sait rien mais
repartir tête baissée comme si s'était
rien passé dans une élection interne ou
tout de suite on va retrouver les mêmes
problèmes que ceux qu'on a connus avant
il ya la culture du chef
donc si vous avez un directoire une
collégialité est ce que ça peut
fonctionner comme ça moi j'ai pas de
prémesques la culture du chef suis
chiraquien
j'ai toujours pensé que comme lui et
pour reprendre sa formule qu'un chef cet
effet pour ces faits mais à condition
qu'ils aient quelque chose à commander
ici voyez ce que je veux dire bon donc
aujourd'hui on en est pas désigner un
chef on est déjà désigné à savoir déjà
pour faire quoi
qu'est ce qu'on veut parce que si vous
le permettez à donner tout de suite dans
le coeur du sujet on est aujourd'hui
pris en tenaille tu me dis juste raison
entre macron d'un côté qui nous dit
venait vers moi et le pen qui de la même
manière dit cela or moi je pense que ce
débat n'est pas le bon mais tout
simplement parce que le clivage n'est
plus de mon point de vue entre la gauche
et la droite
il est entre partis extrémistes est
parti de gouvernement nous sommes un
parti de gouvernement donc nous notre
sujet et de reconquérir cette partie de
l'électorat français qui est pour
défendre l'idée qu'on peut gouverner la
france pas qu'on peut simplement exprimé
un mécontentement dans un espace
politique proche de celui d'emmanuel
mâcon la reconstruction d'affaires sur
cette liste évidemment sur l'échiquier
politique entre la république en marche
et le à rennes pour vous tout simplement
parce que on sait tous que ce qui est
dénoncé par l'extrême droite
ce sont des sujets sur lesquels
extrêmement tu n'as pas de réponse mais
qui sont des questions que nous aurions
dû traiter qu'on n'a pas traité et on
sait que pour toute une série de raisons
macron ne pourra pas les traiter parce
qu'il n'a pas la majorité pour parce
qu'il a même pas l'expérience pour etc
deuxièmement à côté dès que c'est un peu
compliqué sur le plan régaliens c'est la
bronca a semblé donc on verra combien de
temps ça tient deuxième élément
il y à un certain nombre de choses sur
lesquelles emmanuel macron a commis des
erreurs stratégiques
bon autant je suis partisan je les dis
depuis le début de son quinquennat que
l'on soutienne des mesures de droite
qu'on aurait dû faire
voilà gouverner par ordonnance qu il y a
un an jean françois colas vient se
saluent dit à propos des manuels qui
donnerait comme étant de droite qu'on
attende parle de droite qu'on attendait
pas à la fois plus que ce oui bah oui
parce qu'il faisait à sa nombre de
choses que on n'avait pas le courage de
faire sauf contretemps
ben alors quelle erreur il y a par
exemple s'était mis du budget pendant
certains entraînés par exemple dans le
domaine de la dépense publique c'est une
honte ce qui se passe une gabegie inouïe
voilà un domaine dans lequel on doit lui
faire absolument aucune complaisance
d'aucune sorte
il a de la même manière bah oui en quoi
il fait si mal par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs
bah vous me dites ça parce que vous
voulez ma réponse que vous êtes je ne
peux pas croire que vous soyez pas au
courant de ce qui se passe la fuite
la fuite en avant ses déficits ça vient
de loin
oui il sous le général de gaulle est
excédentaire
oui oui c'est pas mon point c'est un peu
loin
attendez je rappelle quand même que nous
tend genton les 100 % de dette sur pib
que nous avons des niveaux de déficits
qui sont extrêmement élevés de notre
déficit budgétaire par rapport aux
autres pays européens je rappelle que
l'allemagne qui a une croyante crise
économique deux fois pire que la nôtre
est aujourd'hui à l'excédent budgétaire
et qui a donc un sacré problème à voir
au fil du temps monsieur macron ne pas
tenir du tout les engagements
budgétaires
sans oublier cette mascarade incroyable
qui est arrivé au moment des gilets
jaunes et où il a gratuitement
redonnez 10 milliards d'euros dont on
sait qu'ils sont perdus pour la cause
bon donc là excusez moi mais sur ce
sujet il est indéfendable je suis
d'autant plus à l'aise pour vous dire
que j'ai soutenu d'autres réformes
je pense qu'il faut privatiser par
exemple aéroports de paris et c'est bon
donc pour moi il y à un véritable espace
pour la droite
mais et c'est ça que je veux vous dire
si on veut vraiment faire ce travail et
je vous disais au début de notre propos
qu'il faut le faire centimètre carré par
centimètre carré
c'est qu'il faut tout reconstruire il
faut aller chercher des gens qui
défendent comme c'est notre tradition
une approche
régaliennes avec un courage en matière
de sécurité il faut d'autre part déjà
rejeté aussi bien sur mes 10 dans des
modèles 15 pouces et a fait la loi anti
casseurs qui vient du sénat qui est une
noire retailleau finalement ils ont
pensé quoi c'est un regard de la droite
de la droite mais rappelez vous à quel
prix combien de mois durant lesquels il
a laissé l'extrême gauche prendre la rue
casser vandaliser dans des conditions
scandaleuses mais non seulement il a
laissé faire mais il a fait preuve d'une
mini expérience inouïe il aurait dû
déclarer les décréter l'état d'urgence
le soir de ce jour funeste pour la
france ou des voyous sont venus
s'installer sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu et ont saccagé l'arc de triomphe
il a été totalement défaillant et plutôt
que de se demander comme certains ce
qu'il fallait mettre le gilet jaune ou
l'enlever le vrai sujet s'étaient tout
de suite vers de réaffirmer aux échanges
avec 100 g bien sûr deuxième élément on
a deuxième élément de la composante de
la droite au même titre que je vous dis
il faut qu'on soit on assume d'être
régalien de manière très claire il faut
de la même manière qu'on assume notre
modèle à la fois libérale et sociale que
l'on soit capable de la même manière de
dire que sur l'europe on est
profondément européen même si on veut
effectivement remettre en cause la
campagne ce traité c'est tout donc
c'était simple on s'excuse et tout le
temps bon et enfin troisième élément que
l'on soit capable d'être sur des valeurs
auxquelles nous croyons sans en rajouter
sur des questions de société du siècle
précédent qui nous braquer évidemment
toute une série d électeurs wolle et
donc c'est pour ça que je vous dit vous
même personnellement sur certains le
mariage gay et j'ai assumé que c'était
certainement la seule décision que
j'avais pu prendre et que je regrettais
ça veut dire que vous regardez par
exemple ça dépend dans quelle condition
mais en tout cas tu prendras comme le
siècle
je pense que c'est un sens de l'humour
développé je vous pourriez être un peu
plus aimable l égard du fait de
l'enquêté ce moment
avec jean françaix la partie en
difficulté je vois quand même vous dire
on vous écoute depuis le début de cette
émission effectivement vous verrez qu'il
y ait une place donc demain pour une
droite rénové mais en même temps on sent
une espèce de petite musique vous êtes
prêt à 10 à une alliance même peut-être
avec la république en marche peut-être
non ya une tentation forte chez sa femme
ruth weale par exemple je me sens encore
une fois non non mais qu'il puisse y
avoir des accords locaux municipal
pourquoi pas moi j'essaie par exemple je
pense qu'à paris il faut tout faire pour
essayer de battre hidalgo ce sera
horriblement difficile parce que
malheureusement la situation fait que
c'est très complexe et pas pour moi qui
suis par exemple
et moi qui suis maire de banlieue je
peux vous dire que ce que anne hidalgo a
fait à paris à l'égard des habitants des
banlieues c'est une honte
depuis des siècles et des siècles les
habitants des banlieues ils apportent
leur force de travail à paris tout a été
organisé pour qu'il puisse plus accéder
à paris en vertu du principe selon
lequel il fallait laisser dans la
quiétude et la tranquillité quelques
bourse aux vélos gérer deux mots voilà
faut aussi des alliances non enfin là en
l'occurrence la situation est un peu du
genre moi personnellement ce que je
recommande à mes amis maires quand ils
peuvent
c'est de ne pas faire de politique
politicienne d'éviter de se mêler de
tout ça et de n'avoir qu'un objectif
proposer un projet à leurs concitoyens
chacun fera comme il l'entendra je pense
en tout cas que à l'heure où nous
parlons le rôle des partis politiques
c'est terriblement a fait c'est que
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
les clivages ne sont plus entre la
gauche et la droite veut pas dire qu'il
ya pas des différences entre la voter à
gauche mais aujourd'hui c'est bien entre
eux les partis de gouvernement et les
partis extrémistes et que dans une
municipalité est bien toutes choses
égales par ailleurs le maire c'est celui
qui gouverne qui porte un certain nombre
d'idées
vassa des extrémistes alors vingt partis
de gouvernement d'un côté le parti
extrémiste de l'autre ben justement le
parti extrémiste et il donne de la voix
en ce moment avec marine le pen qui tend
la main aux responsables de l air est
certain c'est sûr vous le savez vont à
s'élever à 12 on a entendu
la nièce l'attend la famille le pen dire
avec le même enthousiasme que bien
entendu est vraiment ils n'attendaient
que ça de la part de la droite moi pour
tout vous dire je vois bien l'intérêt
pour l'extrême droite d'aller d'aller
chercher des élus de droite je vois pas
du tout l'intérêt pour les élus de
droite d'aller offrir leur nom leur
honneur à l'extrême droite oui je vois
bien l'intérêt pour l'extrême droite tu
ne vois pas pour la droite et je pense
que ce serait rédhibitoire
voilà je lui ai toujours dit c'est mon
combat vg quand j'ai inventé ce concept
de droite décomplexée il ya quelques
années j'avais dit au moins la droite
décomplexée c'est en clair arrêtez de
faire des complexes avec la gauche soucy
et toute une époque
évidemment maintenant c'est un peu
révolu mais pendant des années des
années il fallait être de gauche
voilà ça existe encore dans certains
cénacles 1 mais globalement c'était ça
l'idée quand on n'était pas de gauche on
avait eu un problème certainement dans
son enfance enfin c'était pas nettement
donc moi j'ai assumé l'idée qu'il
fallait absolument se sortir de cela et
être fier d'être de droite mais à une
condition c'est d'être totalement
hermétique avec l'extrême droite
sinon ça n'aurait eu aucun sens et je
pense que c'est ce qui fait la force des
gaullistes des libéraux centristes de
toute cette sensibilité qui de mon point
de vue est majoritaire en france et qui
pour des raisons diverses et variées a
été repoussé dans cette hausse
malheureusement dans une portion congrue
parce que lorsque nous étions pouvoir
nous n'avions pas fait ce pourquoi nous
avions été élu et c'est cela que les
français vous ont reproché à sauter vous
croyez vous aurez toujours des gens qui
vont aller à l'extrême droite y en a
déjà eu là ces dernières semaines les
électeurs faisaient pas pareil je suis
d'accord mais pourquoi c'est autre chose
et ça pèse quand même sûr que ça pèse
bien oui pourquoi c'est autre chose
moi je vois très bien pourquoi par
exemple amour et certaines de mes
administrés vote pour le front national
ils n'en peuvent plus d'un certain
nombre de choses au niveau national de
ce qu'ils voient à la télévision de
beaucoup est donc mais de toute une
série d'éléments qui les gêne qui les
inquiète sur le plan de la sécurité sur
le plan régalien sur le plan de
l'identité de la france
de l'inefficacité du politique aussi
dans de nombreux domaines et donc il ne
croit plus en nous combien de fois j'ai
entendu je l' ai raconté dans mon livre
le sursaut français de janvier mais on
vous croit plus vous faites jamais ce
pourquoi vous êtes élu vous comprenez
donc c'est ça qu'il faut reconstruire et
c'est là dessus qu'il ya un grand défi
pour la droite française
mais comment retrouver sa crédibilité
perdue d'après ce que vous dites et bien
tout simplement en commençant par mettre
les pieds dans le plat dans un certain
nombre d'idées dont on ne va pas voulu
parler et qu'il faut qu'on aborde voilà
par exemple je lui dis la question de
sécurité la question de l'économie
quelle place pour la liberté économique
par rapport à notre pour notre
protection sociale
la question de l'écologie sur lesquels
on laquelle on est très absent la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
à laquelle je tiens beaucoup
un grand livre sur le sujet celui mange
écrit un livre avec laurent alexandre
sur cette thématique de l'intelligence
artificielle
il est inouï que sur ce sujet qui la
grande invention du 21e siècle qui
transforme nos vies la droite soit
silencieuse qui peut le comprendre
aujourd'hui
personne parmi nos concitoyens qu'est ce
que vous pensez l'initiative de gérard
larcher
demain avec les associations d'élus pour
rebâtir la droite à partir des
territoires
moi je pense que damon c'est une
première étape personne ne pense que là
que la droite va se redresser avec
uniquement une réunion d'un cénacle
donner mais je pense qu'il faut bien
démarrer par quelque chose le fait que
gérard larcher qui est président du
sénat lefa c'est une bonne initiative
non il faut pas que ça s'arrête là bas
bien sûr bien sûr après ce qui est
vraiment dire je me suis mais le jeu lui
avait rendu visite au mois de mars pour
pour lui dire c'était il avait un rôle à
jouer justement parce que je voyais
arriver quand même les problèmes et donc
je pense que simplement il faut pas
s'arrêter là ça peut pas être juste un
cénacle avec des présidents de région
des présidents d'associations mais au
moins c'est un début de quelque chose on
verra je pense qu'il faut élargir le
cercle
il faut qu'on y rajoute des tas de gens
personnalités justement y aura beaucoup
chez vous qui peuvent jouer un rôle
majeur qu'elles sont celles qui doivent
être aux avant-postes justement pour
rebâtir la droite ou des façons on va
pas faire du name dropping autonome et
vous n'en savez vous dire une chose et
toutes les personnes qui ont envie de
donner un coup de main sont les
bienvenus on verra on vient de vivre
deux ans assez compliqué ce qu'on était
un peu viré tout donc là si on peut
rouvrir les bras remettre un peu de
bienveillance elle positive voilà est-ce
que le sens très très bien joué moi par
exemple à titre personnel j'ai beaucoup
regretté qu'on laisse partir jean pierre
raffarin
moi je connais très bien chanté enfin
j'étais gdh zebari c'est à lui de dire
enfin moi j'étais son ministre c'est une
personnalité qui comme tous font l'objet
de critiques
franchement je suis un bon spécialiste
dans ce domaine j'en ai pris beaucoup
dont je peux parler librement mais au
moins on a avec jean pierre raffarin
quelqu'un qui a été premier ministre qui
a une expérience qui a une connaissance
internationale c'est dommage qu'il soit
parti alors qu'objectivement voilà c'est
pour être le trait d'union avec le chef
de l'état
non mais vous me demandez voilà je vous
donnerai point de vue là je connaissais
des gens qui doivent revenir oui bah je
pense qu'il est dommage qu'on ait laissé
partir un certain angle de genre le fait
qu'il y ait eu un homme et le fait
qu'ils aient eu un tir de manière un
verrou qui a sauté avec le départ de
laurent wauquiez donne probablement une
nouvelle opportunité de rouvrir nos bras
voilà peu particulier parce que lui a
quitté l'est républicain est-ce que vous
lui tendez la mort le dit il faut
revenir c'est pas mon rôle mais c'est
moi je suis sorti oui bien sûr mais moi
quand tu vois moi je suis je suis sorti
de la politique immédiate trouve que là
depuis 24 ans j'ai décidé de prendre un
peu la parole parce que compte tenu de
mes anciennes fonctions à la tête de
notre famille politique de voir ce
désastre je crois utile de donner un
point de vue bon mais ensuite je serais
tu te places voilà on aurait dit
justement votre place ce sera aux et
qu'elle renouvelait jouer moi j'en mais
franchement si vous aviez passion que
j'étais pas français au début on nous
avait accordé bon de jeter à la rivière
la langue de bois de longue date leur
longueur
on cherche chaque instant jambes à
écouter je fais de mon mieux pour
essayer de ne pas vous décevoir
voilà donc en l'occurrence dans le cas
précis je serai là me voilà enfin je
suis pas quelle place mais en tout cas
je l'aiderai au moins à la réflexion en
partageant un certain nombre d'idées et
que ce qu'ils veulent voilà ce que je
peux aller a vraiment répondu xavier
bertrand est bienvenu mais il n'y a même
pas de débat fin tout le monde écoute et
vu l'état des lieux des tirs pouvaient
remettre un peu de bienveillance l'arbre
est un peu de même un peu d'ambiance et
un truc un peu sympathique en vain de se
regarder en chiens de faïence avec
l'annoncé n'a pas été prononcé à la
pause il continue à rester en retrait ou
est-ce qu'il va s'impliquer de manière
plus franche nicolas sarkozy il doit
avoir son avis à donner sur l'aspect il
a été le président de la république il a
été le chef de famille politique et
enfin sa parole
évidemment elle comptera toujours c'est
une évidence d'accord mais c'était pas
la question
non qu'est ce que c'est la classe dans
la question celle ci doit s'impliquer à
ce qu'il doive jusqu'à revenir et on
vous savez qu'il peut être détecté c'est
peut-être une donnée de lui
j'ai lu le dire moi j'ai pas que
l'initiative vient comité de
renouvellement qui pourrait voir le jour
il ya des jeunes députés 11 jeunes
députés qui veulent ce comité est ce que
vous croyez que vous c'est une bonne
solution c'est une bonne idée pour faire
jaillir mais d'une idée il faut tout le
monde des jeunes des vieux des anciens
des nouveaux d expérimenter des novices
tout le monde
nous sommes complètement à plat il faut
reconstruire
donc on va pas commencer à refaire la
machine à exclure comme on vient de le
vivre depuis 18 mois d'autant que je
voudrais appeler votre attention sur
quelque chose qui m'a quand même
beaucoup frappé c'est que pendant les
six derniers mois les observateurs comme
on dit pudiquement les journalistes donc
ont fracassé emmanuel macron dans des
proportions qui était quand même extrême
gg je rigole toujours avec un journal
qui s'appelle le point voilà qui a fait
une couv couverture comme on dit dans
notre jargon il y a de cela je crois un
mois qui s'appelait sans aucune espèce
de réserve
la droite est revenue avec jet pack 25
pages sur notre candidat françois xavier
bellamy expliquons vraiment c'était
formidable cette droite extradé le même
journal a fait la semaine dernière une
couverture nous remettant emmanuel
macron tel jupiter bon donc c'est vous
dire combien tout ça est relatif et
contingent mais j'observe une chose
c'est que emmanuel macron a visiblement
tout oublié lui et ses amis des périodes
qu'elle vienne de la période précédente
qui sont redevenus des génies et qu'il
n'imagine pas une seconde que ce petit
monde a ce petit défaut d'arrogance
qu'on avait pu parfois très très
gentiment leur faire remarquer et
n'existait plus et lorsque j'ai
découvert dans la presse que des
ministres mandaté par monsieur macron
sont allés expliquer que le ticket
d'entrée était valable encore pour une
semaine et s'était terminée qu'il
fallait vite vite vite adhéré parce
qu'après les représailles seraient
terribles pour les mères le pied ou la
faute de débutant encore parce que cette
arrogance là elle va vite devenir
insupportable et celui qui vous le dit
il a plutôt eu un regard bienveillant je
voulais dit sur un certain nombre des
mesures prises par monsieur macron je
n'ai jamais hurlé au loup sur telle ou
telle de nos anciens amis qui sont
partis au gouvernement parce que deux
manches les aime bien à titre personnel
puis parce que voilà c'est leur choix ça
c'était bien mais c'est leur choix
je voulais je vous disais je vous dise
j'en peux plus de ces de ces mots et ne
il y en a ras-le-bol j'en ai tellement
pris sur la tête je n'en veux plus en
tout cas moi je ne les utiliserait pas
en revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que les
voir pour certains d'entre eux fait
repêcher d'arrogance menacé ceux qui ne
les ont pas encore rejoint je me dis que
ce n'est pas très commun n'est pas très
convaincant le ministre le corps nus dit
justement aux élus et l'herbe quitter
votre partie quitté le parti de voter
c'est plus que de l'arrogance encore à
bas il est allé beaucoup plus loin
alors il
comme ses collègues ont expliqué qu'ils
avaient il fallait aller très très vite
parce qu'un jour le ticket ne serait
plus valable enfin et c'est bon comment
dire on a connu tout ça en d'autres
temps hein c'est pas c'est pas très
convenable
edouard philippe qui a beaucoup fait
campagne dans des villes de droite
pendant seize européenne n'a pas réussi
sa mission d'attirer à lui les électeurs
de droite
alors écoutez il ya un vieux proverbe
qui la victoire à sion perd la défaite
est orpheline je pense que nous aurions
tous dit qu'ils avaient terriblement
échoué si son score avait été mauvais il
a aussi très bien bravo formidable
résumé je vous dis ça y est c'est fait
maintenant c'est derrière nous pas bien
mais c'est leur philippe siphonner la
droite temps de dire clairement
baboo fin je précise edouard philippe
enfin en tout cas nous on a perdu nos
électeurs ils sont partis au front
national d'un côté et chez en marche
l'autre considère effectivement ce soir
est d'ailleurs pour citer le point
puisque c'était d'éditorial de la
semaine dernière vous considérer qu'on a
toujours besoin de la droite en france
non seulement on a besoin de la droite
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même que
chacun de ceux qui nous écoutent et bien
en tête une chose la victoire
de le pen la présidence de la république
ça ne peut pas être simplement une
option inenvisageable
c'est quelque chose qui est maintenant
un fait ça n'est pas une assurance pour
le savent de qui peut exister et
emmanuel macron prend un risque
historique à vouloir se positionner seul
face à l'extrême droite
parce qu'en réalité le risque que un
jour parfait comme un autre comme on dit
les français on est vraiment marre de
lui dans trois ans et se disent on ne
peut vraiment plus de lui donc on veut
quelqu'un d'autre qu'est-ce qui nous
qu'est ce qu'on a on à l'extrême droite
et que pour peu que madame le pen est
les deux ou trois mots qui vont bien du
genre oh mais votez pour moi puis après
vous corrigerez aux législatives
sauf que le mal il fait est qu après
c'est trop tard bon donc moi je vous dis
la droite c'est le rempart à ce risque
et il faut qu'elle se remette très très
vite autant qu'elle le peut autant
qu'elle le peut en ordre de bataille
offert une jaguar alternative pour
proposer un choix alternatif en partie
le gouvernement à monsieur macro mais ce
que vous diriez comme brice hortefeux
tout à l'heure par exemple que emmanuel
macron et marine le pen sont en
politique en des frères siamois
alors je sais pas parce que j'ai pas
entendu cette démonstration ne veux pas
vous en dire plus et que les deux
finalement le serbe
si l'idée de dire qu'il dise on en a
l'eau validé l'idée de dire qu'ils ont
une alliance objective par rapport à
l'est que vous faites écarter les autres
familles politiques bas c'est vrai
aujourd'hui mais enfin on a le droit de
perturber ce bel en ce bel
ordonnancement mais si on la comprend
alors on avait dit du temps de françois
mitterrand 1 qu' il avait cherché à
faire monter justement le front national
diriez-vous qu emmanuel macron c'est
mitterrand empire en matière de
stratégies électorales les mitterrand
pire restons calme chez chaque histoire
est différente on la compare ya tout ce
pauvre mâcon nous avons expliqué que
c'était jupiter bon j'avais une autre
image moins de jupiter quand j'étais
jeune bon il l'accord elle même moi j'ai
pas c'est pas tout fait mais vous dire
je suis moins sac à main après on a
comparé de gaulle
là aussi je trouve que c'est excessif
c'est pas pourquoi enfin vous voyez un
truc je sais bien qu'on est dans la
cible dans la société de l'instantanéité
mais arrêtons tout cela comparé
mitterrand à mâcon a strictement aucun
sens
il a fait un vieux truc bien connu
il consiste à essayer des cartes et de
descartes et son principal adversaire du
départ qui était nous en faisant une
alliance avec les failles d'alliance
objective en fait avec l'extrême droite
bon très bien il faut qu'on a on
n'enraye ce processus infernal et c'est
notre mission
une majorité de français qui trouvent
que le rassemblement national s'est
normalisée qu'il sait dédiaboliser
finalement avec marine le pen
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
marine le pen est toujours un obstacle
pour certains électeurs de droite et est
ce que la figure de marion maréchal
pourrait faire que la dic saute il faut
tout faire pour l'empêcher
ces îles pendant très longtemps moi j'ai
essayé de répondre aux arguments d'un
certain nombre de gens d'aimer quand
même regarde le ps qui s'est allié avec
le pc qui fait des alliances avec
l'extrême gauche pourquoi est ce que
nous on ne ferait pas avec le front
national c'est pas si grave après tout
c'est bon et donc moi j'essaie
d'expliquer que manon parce que la
france n est pas une page blanche que
l'extrême droite c'était quand même des
gens qui étaient d'abord là pour
déstabiliser avec de temps en temps des
relents qui ne correspondait pas à ce
qu'on peut qu'attendre du pays et donc
maintenant j'ai pris une décision en
fait c'est que je ne m'explique plus
j'ai décidé que j'arrête d'être
démontrée je suis contre cette alliance
points comme je respecte tout à fait
ceux qui n'ont pas cet avis mais moi je
considère à partir de maintenant que ça
n'est même plus du domaine respecter
ceux qui n'ont pas cet avis
nos avions en face de nous la semaine
dernière eric ciotti qui nous a dit
qu'en 2022 s'il ya un nouveau duel au
second tour entre maquereau et le pen
est bien il ferait avec comme en 2017 il
ne se déplacera pas pour voter et on se
souvient que françoise s'abstiendra on
se souvient que françois-xavier bellamy
au soir du premier tour de 2017 avait
dit qu'il refusait de choisir également
et de céder à un diktat moral donc là
c'est surtout laurent wauquiez qui l'a
dit mais est-ce que c'est là aussi le
péché originel je pense que c'est l'un
d'eux qui a conduit cette situation à
cette situation
je pense profondément je crois que
c'était une erreur
immense parce que la tradition de notre
famille politique notamment la tradition
gaulliste je sens triste aussi
jacques barrot c'était justement de
faire un rempart total et nous avons eu
un bureau politique absolument atroce
est un des plus mauvais souvenir
politique de ma vie j'en ai d'autres
mais celui là était vraiment très dur
durant lequel avec un certain nombre de
mes deux de mes amis
baroin chatel je me souviens il y avait
n'était trop quatre essais deux de
batailler pour pour faire acter que on
devait tous unanimement appelé à voter
macron face à l' pour faire barrage à le
pen elle voit on n'avait jamais laurent
beauté avec famille laurent wauquiez
cite opposé fortement donc on a sorti
une espèce de phrasé ciotti aussi
d'ailleurs une phrase un peu alambiqué
expliquant que je peux quand j'ai même
plus la phrase qu'on avait on voit donc
tout ça était absolument voilà désolé
encore locaux est-ce qu'on voit pas
comment vous les expliquer que vous êtes
contre une alliance mais écoutez comment
vous pouvez expliquer que vous êtes
contre une alliance avec le rnd niveau
national mais vous êtes pour niveau
local
les électeurs d'une municipalité céder
sous électeurs par rapport aux électeurs
de la prétendue république c'est la même
chose
une question d'un internaute du figaro
pour vous jean françois copé ce sera la
dernière question puisque après vous
avez céder votre place à gaspard grande
soeur vous avez évoqué votre
détermination à tout faire pour que anne
hidalgo s'est battu on l'interrogera sur
le sujet tout à l'heure question donc
d'un internaute du figaro live vous vous
aviez
vous étiez déclaré
membre de la droite décomplexée vous
l'avez rappelé dans cette émission vous
qu'il a fait et maintenant vous lui
reprochez alors bon d'abord point numéro
un je n'étais pas membre de la droite
est composée j'ai inventé le concept
s'est choisie c'est pas l'un des seuls
que j'ai inventé donc ses passagers j'en
aurais fait beaucoup je ferai le malin
mais c'est un des rares donc voilà
bloqué la serrure proches et
deuxièmement vaud qui ne l'a pas fait
puisque le concept de droite décomplexée
justement et je le dis est vraiment une
manière très très amicale de cet
internaute que je ne connais pas mais
que les choses soient très claires il
l'a pas fait parce que les vins et je
dis donc à eva ils sont une erreur à
wauquiez c'est que il n'ya pas appliquer
le concept la droite décomplexée
c'était d'être très ferme vis-à-vis de
la gauche mais également totalement
hermétique avec l'extrême droite et il
ya eu des ambiguïtés tout le temps
durant ces deux années entre certains
tracts qu'ils étaient des copier coller
du front national où le fait que par
exemple on virait il avait viré virginie
calmels ce qui était plutôt la
sensibilité libérale mais que dans le
même temps ils disaient rien à des
jeunes militants et l'eire qui s'affiche
ostensiblement avec des militants fn
donc forcément c'était d ambiguïté
permanente et ça c'est ça mon avis a
conduit petit à petit au rétrécissement
notre famille politique merci beaucoup
jean françois copé d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour cette première partie de
l'audition publique
merci mesdames la suite avec maintenant
gagnent donc gaspard grande soeur qui
fait son entrée dans ce studio avec nos
deux confrères journalistes
[Musique]
gaspard cancer donc s'installe bonsoir
et merci d'être là avec nous avec
vincent roux du figaro et du figaro live
vincent bonsoir et paulo brésil afp
alors soit plus vert que moi tu seras
meilleur de paris gaspard ganzer joli ça
dans vos intentions programme bien sûr
vous êtes candidat sans étiquette aux
municipales à paris avec une étiquette
la nôtre oui par les ira riziers le
parisien c'est maintenant on en est
qu'au la voix de l'ancien maire bertrand
delanoë il aimait bien commencé ses
discours de cette manie toujours la main
sur le coeur parisienne parisien alors
vous vous revendiquez de l'écologie on
l'a compris comment est-ce que l'ancien
conseiller de caen communication de
françois hollande se met aujourd'hui à
agir pour lui même et pour la capitale
bah c'est un long chemin puisque l'on
compass pas de l'ombre à la lumière
comme ça d'un coup d'un seul mais c'est
vrai que j'ai été longtemps le
conseiller d'autres personnalités
bertrand delanoë françois hollande
laurent fabius et un moment je me suis
dit bon je vais avoir 40 ans il était
temps de défendre soi-même ses propres
idées pas seul d'ailleurs mais avec un
collectif et c'est bien d'avoir des
convictions qu'on ait 20 ans 30 ans 40
ans ou plus et moi j'ai bien envie de
les défendre elle confond de défendre
celle des parisiennes et des parisiens
faingaa spyder vous l'avez dit vous avez
conseillé plusieurs personnalités
socialistes
et puis vous savez également dit que
vous aviez voté yannick jadot aux
européennes il ya ya quinze jours alors
que candidat europe ecologie les verts à
paris il existe c'est daniel bédard il
devrait avoir droit
david habib beye n'a pas votre voix
c'est un candidat pour la mairie de
paris
je pense qu'à chaque élection les choses
se configure de façon différente
moi j'ai voté pour la république en
marche de figurez-vous aux élections
présidentielles et pour 24 heures 24
heures/24
c'est une belle bêtise oui de trois ans
jusqu'au dépenses était à rennes j'adore
les bretons surtout les bretons de paris
j'espère qu'ils voteront pour nous mais
en réalité je n'avais aucune attache
avec la bretagne cela n'a aucun sens
d'aller là bas donc j'ai voté pour une
macro ce que je pensais que c'était la
meilleure décision pour cette élection
et au niveau européen je pensais que
c'était la question écologique qui était
la plus importante est que c'était
yannick jadot qui était la mieux placée
pour la porter au niveau net municipalié
audi vainqueur ici en tant que c'est pas
quelqu'un de bien
rim ecologie les verts avec des labels
jarriot et bien figurez vous que je
pense que le prochain d'un de paris aura
des convictions écologistes et sera même
un maire écologiste
alors après est ce que ça sera le maire
un maire eux élevés ou quelqu'un qui
comme moi au sein de parisienne
parisiens portent des convictions
écologistes très fort je crois que
l'écologie n'appartient à personne non
plus très gros plutôt exactement elle
appartient à tout le monde c'est parce
que c'est ça le plus important
alors il ya une surenchère écolo gaspard
rien de ça pour la candidature à paris
et vous n'êtes pas absent dans cette
surenchère puisque vous proposait de
tout bonnement tout simplement la
suppression du périphérique
alors question comment dans ces
conditions mais tant que vous soyez le
maire de paris que la cette mesure soit
votée comment font les habitantes
banlieue de boulogne de saint-cloud de
saint denis de saint maur pour se rendre
dans d'autres villes de banlieue ils
doivent se farcir du coup les
embouteillages monstres déjà que se
farcissent les parisiens pour aller de
banlieue à banlieue
alors si vous me permettez je conviens
11 secondes sur le pourquoi avant de
venir sur le comment parce que c'est
quand même intéressant de savoir
pourquoi est ce qu'on a proposé au sein
de parisienne parisien cette mesure la
première raison c'est que paris est la
seule grande métropole mondiale à avoir
une autoroute urbaine deux fois 4 voies
à 5 km de son centre
cette autoroute urbaine elle est
extrêmement polluantes elle pose des
problèmes de santé ont indiqué les
responsables de 25% de la population en
ile de france
oui c'est le brevet soit 44 un quart et
un tiers il ya près de deux cent mille
personnes qui vivent juste aux abords du
périphérique notamment des enfants
il ya des écoles à côté du périphérique
on a du mal à y croire des crèches les
équipements publics des stades de foot
des lycées et ces gens ils subissent la
pollution sonore et atmosphérique ça
c'est la première raison c'est
affreusement laid ce qui compte
l'esthétique dans une ville si paris est
la plus belle ville du monde je pense
que le périphérique est l'endroit le
plus laid de paris elle sans aucun
conteste et la troisième chose c'est que
paris est bridée dans son expansion n'a
pas assez d'air et toof parce qu'il ya
cette frontière artificielle ce mur qui
enferme paris donc c'est pour ça qu'on
propose de le supprimer
non pas en quinze jours ou en 15 heures
mais en 15 ans le temps de construire
les alternatives pour permettre
justement
alors voilà il y en a 3 3 type
d'alternative
la première c'est qu'il faut permettre
aux gens qui font des trajets
internationaux
la personne qui fait barcelone bruxelles
ou nantes strasbourg qui aujourd'hui
passent par les périphériques ont fait
une sorte de détour pour se rapprocher
du centre de la capitale avant de
repartir vers une autre ville du
d'europe ou de province eh bien elle
doit pouvoir contourner plus largement
la ville par l'a86 et la france yen qui
existe déjà
ça tombe bien mais qui sont pas assez
utilisé à plein pour les habitants de
proche banlieue
il faut y aller sans la 80 alors c'est
la deuxième c'est le trafic régional
c'est le deuxième tiers eux ils ont
vocation quand même apprendre qu'on
appelle le grand paris express vous
savez c'est ce grand métro qui avait été
inventée par nicolas sarkozy qui a un
peu tardé à se mettre en place et qui
permet justement le couteau nom de paris
qui doit permettre d'absorber ce trafic
et puis enfin pour les gens qui sont des
parisiens ou qui habite vraiment très
proche de paris et boulogne montreuil
eux ils doivent bénéficier d'autres
solutions le métro le bus l'autopartage
le covoiturage le vélo
et puis aussi il n'a pas bronché voiture
pas honnêtement quand votre camp vous
habitez à boulogne et que vous allez un
porte d'orléans je suis patient vous
avez besoin de prendre une voiture je l
assume peut-être que ça ne plaira pas
aux personnes qui habitent à boulogne
qui vont porte d'orléans en voiture mais
je crois que quand on va de boulogne à
porte d'orléans voiture on n'est pas
obligé d'être seul programme en fait
c'est un programme pour les parisiens
mais qui sacrifierait de banlieusards
pas du tout parce que justement la
suppression du périphérique doit
permettre de réconcilier paris et sa
banlieue
si aujourd'hui et cette séparation
artificielle est dans la tête mais
surtout physique c'est parce qu'à ce
périphérique je sais pas si vous êtes
déjà allé récemment porte d'orléans au
porte de montreuil ou encore peu plus
haut encore pire au nord de paris
il ya vraiment cette ségrégation urbaine
entre le nord de bari le sud de paris
l'est et l'ouest
et là on va en parler parce que oui on y
revient et ça c'est très intense
je pense que le périphérique est une des
cause de la séparation entre paris et sa
banlieue
si on veut réconcilier paris et sa
banlieue si on veut retrouver de l'air
si on veut retrouver de l'espace il faut
supprimer cette barrière extrêmement
polluante de 35 kg mais ce que vous avez
quelque chose contre les déplacements
individuels en automobile par exemple
électrique parce que là on il ya des
verts quand même vous êtes peut-être
plus vert que certains verts est-ce que
vous acceptez encore que il ya une forme
de liberté de se déplacer dans une
automobile bien sûr si c'est si celle ci
n'est pas polluant bien sûr si celle ci
n'est pas polluante et si on
périphériques ils pourront pas
l'utiliser il y aura cannes des rues
dans paris un jour assure on va pas
supprimer toutes les rues il y aura
quand même des raisons expliquent notre
partage
il n'y a plus d'eau libre aujourd'hui
malheureusement parce que c'est un
service qui marchait bien qui a été
arrêté il ya quelques mois maintenant si
on peut se dépasser alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez électrique on peut se déplacer
aussi à pied c'est formidable c'est vrai
que c'est le premier mode déplacement
des parisiens
la marche à pied à vélo à rouiba bien
sûr on marche pour prendre le métro pour
attraper son bus mais qu'est ce que vous
faites des hectares par centaines libéré
parce qu'alors je vois le programme des
verts aujourd'hui monsieur belliard
david de son prénom qui contestent
désormais toute construction et vous
aussi un peu où vous êtes contre le
béton vous voulez tout verdir mais
l'argument qui est avancée notamment par
votre concurrent vert c'est de dire on
ne peut pas construire corps ça va
contre le climat
alors dites moi on en vient la main du
côté de ménilmontant on va pas être trop
parisienne non plus oui la supprimer un
programme avec plus de 80 logements
sociaux en misouk 80 logements sociaux
rayés comme ça d'un trait de plume parce
que c'est mauvais pour les collines
marre je vais quand même essayer de
répondre sur ce point très particulier
effectivement qui concerne un endroit de
ménilmontant le haut le nom du 11e et
limite avec le 20e c'est une des zones
les plus bêtes au départ il est plus
dense de paris il n'était pas nécessaire
de recréer un immeuble supplémentaires
alors qu'on a besoin d'espacé dans cette
zone ont malheureusement mais pas dans
cette zone je prends pas dans cette zone
en revanche ma divergences peut-être
avec monsieur belliard que j'apprécie
par ailleurs et qui a été désigné la
semaine dernière c'est que je pense
qu'on doit exploiter intelligemment les
centaines d'hectares qu'on pourra
récupérer avec la destruction du
périphérique selon les estimations entre
200 et 300 hectares je pense qu'il faut
qu'il y ait entre 100 et 150 hectares
qu'ils soient consacrés à des nouveaux
espaces verts et les deux autres tiers
on récupérera qu'ont-ils qu'il soit pour
faire des logements soit pour faire des
équipements publics des crèches des
ehpad débit bio
avec votre concurrentes peut-être une
des principales s'est naturellement la
mer auront poste a lancé la maire
sortante c'est la favorite
anne hidalgo est favorite selon vous
balleux quand on est maire sortant et
qu'on a tous les moyens de la
municipalité
normalement on part avec une longueur
d'avancé après les gens questionne son
bilan on verra quel est son projet et si
effectivement elle est candidate mais
sur la ligne de départ on est toujours
avec une un temps d'avant ce qu'on est
favori mais ça ne rentre
j'avoue que ce qui est idéal socialiste
est pourquoi vous ne soutenez pas
finalement qu'est ce que vous lui
reprochez benjamin griveaux peut-être
l'un de vos concurrents de la république
en marche il parle par exemple d'un
comportement chronique il est sur des
problèmes celui de personnalités est-ce
que vous aussi vous avez sur ce
terrain-là de la personnalité d'agdal go
ou est-ce que ça c'est un biberon
certainement pas parce que ce jeu serait
mal placé pour le faire j'ai travaillé
plusieurs années la ville de paris
charrier cinq ans la ville de paris
auprès de christophe girard puis après
c'est d'abord auprès de bertrand delanoë
gens que j'apprécie humainement et j'ai
travaillé aussi avec anne hidalgo
indirectement attendant voilà projet à
dire un truc j'ai même voté pour elle en
2014 il n'en reste pas moins que
j'estime qu'aujourd'hui après 20 ans
d'une majorité socialiste et communiste
et verte à la ville de la ville de paris
avec à peu près les mêmes personnalités
qui gouverne de la ville depuis 20 ans
je pense qu'on a un besoin de
renouvellement d'air frais premièrement
et la deuxième chose c'est que on a
besoin d'un nouveau projet l'idée c'est
pas simplement de réfléchir à faire
quelques mètres de tramway en plus ou
quelques logements sociaux en plus je
pense qu'il faut réfléchir à paris en
grand mais très largement c'est pour ça
que je propose de supprimer le
périphérique c'est parce que je pense
qu'il faut de la radicalité dans notre
approche de paris paris est trop petit
quand on va à new york on va à berlin
qu'on va à rome quand on va à londres la
ville et 2 les vignes sont deux fois
trois fois plus grandes elles ont plus
d'air plus de place pour faire des
espaces verts plus d espace pour
respirer
nous on a cette surconcentration qui
fait que l'os est lié aussi au
corporatisme des élus parisiens ils
veulent pas abandonner leur genre voir
sur le terrain je n'aurais pas leurs
passes mais je pense qu'il faut et
généreux et solidaire faut pas avoir
peur de dépasser les frontières
actuelles de paris fait d'accord je
préfère attaquer éviter de traverser les
gens mais cette violence que je resserre
ce que j'observe c'est que depuis vingt
ans on ne l'a pas fait en réalité ce ce
changement de paradigme ce changement de
concept changement d'échelle qui aurait
permis de construire paris en grand et
de faire l'équivalent du grand nom
l'équivalent du grand berlin lui qu'il
est ce qu'on avait un temps delanoë
pense la même chose que vous quand vous
dites qu effectivement après 20 ans il
faut une forme d'alternance apparaît
vous savez j'ai travaillé longtemps avec
bertrand delesne justement les choses il
ya une chose que je sais c'est qu'il ne
supporte pas qu'on parle à sa place j'ai
été son porte parole ce n'est pas facile
tous les jours même si j'ai adoré ça
donc si vous avez des questions à lui
poser vous lui poserez donc le jour de
vous parler amicalement mais il ne me
soutient pas on dit qu'il ne croyait le
soutien personnel non justement on dit
qu'il a pris a effectivement anne
hidalgo en grippe les vous lui
demanderez honnêtement je pense que ça
sera la limite de notre conversation
si vous voulez savoir ce que bertrand
delanoë se passe il faut lui demander
tout à l'heure jean françois copé qui
était sûr à votre place disait à propos
de la l'élection amérique paris qu'il
fallait tout faire pour battre
anne hidalgo est ce que c'est votre avis
mais c'est pas un objectif de sortir la
maire sortante même s'il ya certainement
des parisiens qui voudraient du
changement je pense qu'on n'est pas
candidat contre quelqu'un on est
candidat pour quelque chose
moi je suis candidat pour verdir cette
ville la dp2 dép étonné comme vous
l'avez dit la rendre plus solidaire plus
écologique et plus grande plus
respirable et conçoit paris en mai je
dirais jamais que je veux dégommer untel
ou untel question différemment gaspard
genser si par exemple vous n'arrivez pas
au second tour ou avec un score
suffisant au premier tour à supposer que
vous maintenez votre candidature et qu'
il y a anne hidalgo face à benjamin
griveaux il ya un dicton populaire qui
dit avec des si on mettrait paris en
bouteille il vous avez raison nous poser
cette question de cette manière mais je
n'y répondrai pas parce qu'en fait je ne
me mettrais pas dans cette perspective
vous savez quand on se lance vous
pourrez vous aviez avec l'animal go par
exemple
en fait je ne mène jamais ma réfléchir à
manier avec telle ou telle personne
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le fond et des
projets qui est pour ou contre la
suppression du périphérique ainsi que
j'ai apprécié en ce moment la question
se pose que non mais il faut près fait
chier enfin je suis désolé je vais pas
vous faire la leçon ça serait
désagréable mais j'ai pas envie de
réfléchir à partir des parties ou partir
des personnes j'ai bêtement j'ai soupé
de la politique politicienne
le côté les mécanos aux permanents
d'ailleurs visiblement ce n'est pas fini
tant à droite qu'à gauche et même
ailleurs vraiment ça ne m'intéresse pas
en avant dans les terres c'est pour ou
contre la suppression du prénom et les
autres ce qu'on veut faire on va passer
en revue en main sur les questions
sociales ceux des questions économiques
sur les questions éducatives sur la
question des crèches et surtout c'est
par exemple sur la question
on va prendre la police municipale pour
ou contre alors moi je suis pour la
police municipale mais je vais vers
compte visiblement oui je pense qu'ils
ont tort parce qu'on a des polices
municipales manque aujourd'hui à paris
on a besoin de police municipale qui
soit évidemment contrôler qu'ils soient
bien formés pour exercer ses missions
mais elle manque aujourd'hui dans
l'espace public la police nationale trop
d'autres chats à fouetter doivent gérer
la lutte contre le terrorisme la lutte
contre la grèce communalité ils peuvent
pas gérer cette police du quotidien qui
devrait exister depuis longtemps à paris
anne hidalgo
qu'est ce que c'est le gaspard gonzo
risque c'est qu'il a fait c'est de
gauche et de droite et du centre on peut
être ne pas être dans la politique
politicienne n'a pas négocié ferris set
ça aurait été désagréable ça aurait été
extrêmement désagréable j'ai jamais vous
savez j'évite de me regarder moi même
parce que je n'avance pas bidart est
arrivé bien sûr mais je me dis pas tous
les matins en me disant est ce que tu as
droite et suez de gauche parce qu'en
fait je ne sais même plus ce que ça veut
dire j'espère est ce que vous savez ce
que ça veut dire d'être de gauche et de
droite jean françois copé les
socialistes je ne peux être que j'ai
écouté ce qu'il a dit sur le sujet les
socialistes eux mêmes ne savent plus
répondre à cette question
la droite non plus en revanche moi je
sais quelles sont mes valeurs et c'est
comme ça que je réfléchis je suis
attaché à l'écologie je me suis attachée
à la lutte contre les inégalités et à la
solidarité je veux construire paris en
grand je pense qu'on a besoin d'un tract
y vite
économiques pour cette ville est ce que
c'est de droite est ce que c'est de
gauche je ne sais pas je suis pour les
rues soient enfin propre que les trous
dans la rue soit bouché est ce que c'est
de droite est ce que ces deux objets
grâce à wii à l'évidence il ya des
évidences eux il ya beaucoup de nuits
poule
moi j'ai fait mon temps du scooter
maintenant je fais du vélo c'est quand
même un en fait on a l'impression de
faire le paris-dakar tous les jours qui
n'arrive pas parce que là franchement
quels sont les effectifs de la ville de
paris pour les connaissent et oui bien
sûr il ya plus de cinquante mille paires
50 millions la commission européenne
comme on aime en dit toujours
effectivement on compare avec
effectively c'est d'ailleurs ce à
domicile par les technocrates mais à
paris on a cinquante mille
fonctionnaires munitions alors qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils font des choses utiles
ils sont dans les crèches
ils sont dans les écoles publiques parce
qu'il aimait bien son nom je pense que
ne faut pas attaquer les agents en
revanche je pense qu'ils n'ont pas été
coaché on va dire ou piloter ce qu'on
fait est suffisamment bien je crois que
quand on est maire de paris on doit être
un bon manager comme un chef
d'entreprise on va être capable
d'affecter la ressource financière et la
ressource humaine au bon endroit et je
pense qu'on appelle la science du détail
voyez-vous critique harnais d'algos
quand même beaucoup à celle ci pouvait
évoquer également le déficit croissant
de la vie alors je pense qu'il ya des
choses qu'il ya deux choses que je peux
dire sur le trait directement sur la
majorité actuelle je pense qu on l a
perdu le contrôle de l'espace public on
voit le bordel excusez moi sur les
trottinettes à l'heure actuelle et tous
les accidents qu elle préoccupe la
saleté des rues les trous dans les rues
donc ça c'est un vrai problème les gens
se sentent brio la chapelle on en parle
oui après la délinquance vraiment
d'aider les endroits qui sont devenues
insupportables roulée par sfr je ne
connais tu mens il faudrait que vous lui
demandiez invité là je pense qu'elle
sera ravi de venir et puis elle l est
pas du tout susceptible donc vous verrez
elle avec beaucoup de plaisir à 7 à
cette question du troisième jeu le
joueur s'est pas je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle est je ne sais pas ce qu'elle a
fait ou ce qu'elle n'a pas fait en
revanche que je re plus que j'observe
c'est vous reprocher aussi ce que
j'observe c'est que la majorité actuelle
n'a pas su bien gérer l'espace public or
l'espace public c'est là où les gens
vivent ensemble la rue où ils passent de
chez eux à leur travail à leurs habits à
leur loisir là où il emmène les enfants
quand vous allez dans un parc et vous
tombez sur des rats évidemment ce n'est
pas très agréable
on aurait envie d'en rire mais en fait
il faudrait surtout en pleurer à des
caméras
dans les rats ne sont pas apparus avec
anne hidalgo on les voit à l'évidence il
ya quand même plus de travaux alors je
sais pas comment se passe la
coordination alors la ville de paris
n'est pas à l'origine de tous ces
travaux on a d'autres qui mène de
prestataires ou deux partenaires n'a en
revanche la ville de paris à la cnps
responsabilité c'est de les gérer
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'il ya
une sorte d'immense chasse au trésor qui
a été lancée dans la ville de paris et
6000 travaux c'est facile à retenir
puisqu'elle 6000 rue donc on attend
moins un parent eux alors haut de gamme
at on appris aujourd'hui que vos amis ou
anciens amis de la république en marche
avait mis en presque leur commission
nationale d'investiture pour les
municipales à paris on sait qu'il aura
notamment benjamin griveaux qui est
candidat milliards nage ou bi cédric
villani et sonar grand sens du projet
sont évidemment si vous êtes proche de
lui d'ailleurs dû déroger vous savez
j'ai été j'ai été à l'école avec nous
avec rançon à paris vos on ait la même
génération je pense que c'est bien
qu'ils aient une nouvelle génération qui
va essayer à l'école avec mc ren aussi
voilà il ya une nouvelle il ya une
nouvelle génération qui vous prendre le
pouvoir et c'est très bien il a imposé
5-1 nouvellement précisément qu'est ce
qui vous sépare d'une part de ses
candidats macronix ya aussi des traits
de caractère d'un jeu malgré votre est
attaqué sur sa personnalité sur son
image vous rejoignez ses critiques aussi
par exemple vous savez où je le connais
dans un cadre privé donc il a jamais été
désagréable avec moi enfin jusqu'à
présent j'espère que ça ne changera pas
après j'ai travaillé longtemps des
domaines de la communication et je sais
que parfois on projette une image qui ne
correspond pas à ce que l'on est
il faut une beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup de temps arrivera un jour à
changer son image puisqu'on lui a dit
moi jeune harold koh a déjà travaillé
sur la mienne et ça suffit largement jeu
des je laisse aux autres le soin de
s'occuper leur propre image mais sur le
fond ce test si vous me permettez de
répondre je pense qu'un ensemble de
clivage qui se paye un premier clivage
sur pourquoi la république on marche a
été créée la république en marche qui
s'appelle la république d'emmanuel
macron le m
il a été créé pour cela en hommage au
président de la république et c'est vers
un seul objectif c'est de permettre la
conquête du pouvoir au niveau national
emmanuel macron ils y sont arrivés
d'ailleurs chapeau chapeau bas j'ai même
voté pour eux en revanche ils n'ont pas
été créées pour renouveler la ville de
paris et moi je crois que pour paris il
faut un mouvement strictement parisien
qui a comme seul objectif les
parisiennes les parisiens et paris ça
c'est une première différence moi je
n'ai pas d'autres agendas
je ne cours pas les régionales je ne
cours pas la présidentielle je cours pas
les européennes c'est tout pour paris
rennes pour paris et je n'ai pas
d'agenda caché je pense que ça fait une
première différence
la deuxième c'est que moi ça fait deux
ans déjà que je suis sur le terrain à la
boue est allé voir les gens
d'autres étaient gouvernement d'autres
défendent et le président la république
ils ont bien le droit mais c'est un
autre job et une autre mission est la
troisième chose c'est sur le fond je
pense qu'on a des clivages assez fort
par exemple je sais qu'ils sont contre
le projet de destruction et de
transformation de l'espace périphériques
je pense que sur les questions
écologiques
nous avons des vraies divergences j'ai
une proposition si vous permettez de
l'énoncé qui est de construire dix mille
places en crèches supplémentaires et de
rendre gratuite
les crèches les habitants par an alors
bouzzine ce qui est déjà beaucoup
et le 12 mille fois cinquante et
soixante mille moi je croise les gens
qui partent sont les familles parce
qu'elles n'ont pas assez de service
quand vous êtes que vous êtes une salle
ya quelque chose pour les familles ah
ben moi je j'ai présenté ma candidature
dans le parisien qui est à fond quand
j'en suis désolé en dix ans je voulais
être le candidat de toutes races et de
toutes les familles parisiennes de
toutes les familles de toutes les formes
que ce soit des familles monoparentales
des familles nombreuses des familles
recomposées comme la mienne toutes
sortes de familles pourquoi parce que je
pense que le sont les familles qui
souffrent le plus à paris c'est elle qui
ont du mal à se loger celles qui n'ont
pas places en crèche c'est elle qui au
stress sur l'école de langue qu'est ce
que vous leur proposez puisque vous êtes
si on doit retenir une seule mesure ce
que je voulais que tu tiens c'est
vraiment la gratuité des crèches et la
création de dix mille places
supplémentaires et je vais aller plus
loin je pense qu'il faut même créé une
forme de droit opposable à la garde
d'enfant comme il existe un droit
opposable au logement serre que la ville
de paris et le département paris puisque
ces deux collectivités sont fusionnés à
paris doivent garantir à tous les
parisiens et tous les parisiennes une
solution de garde que ce soit une
solution de garde temporaire type
halte-garderie l'accès à une nounou
l'accès à des baby-sitters s'il s'agit
juste de trouver du temps en fin de
journée une place en crèche c'est pas
normal aujourd'hui qu'un service public
financé par l'impôt
c'est le cas des crèches ne soit pas
assez que cible à tous il ya une
personne sur deux qui se voir refuser
une place en crèche aujourd'hui mais est
ce que le problème majeur de paris
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on constate dans
les quartiers avec peut-être
de nouveaux ghettos et c'est qui on peut
vivre apparition des très riches ou si
on est très pauvre
je suis content que la classe moyenne
est balayé je suis content de l'entendre
dire parce que paris la situation la
population parisienne ce comme ça d'un
élastique qui se tend et qui menace de
craquer entre des gens très riches qui
peuvent acheter des appartements à
crazannes 20000 raciste 15 15 mille
jeunes utiliserait pas ce terme l'armé
des gens très pauvres qui ont parfois la
chance d'avoir des logements dans les
logements sociaux ou alors qu'ils sont à
la rue il ya des enfants dans les rues
il ya des sdf
il ya des migrants ya des gens qui sont
laissés à eux mêmes et au milieu il ya
des classes moyennes qui tira tirent le
diable par la queue savent pas maqué 120
et qu'ils sont voilà exactement parce
que quand arrive le deuxième enfant
quand il ya un divorce et d'ail non plus
les moyens de se loger et comme il n'y a
pas assez de services qui leur est
offert et bien il songe à quitter la
ville sont obligés de la fuir que les
gens partent de paris pour aller vivre
ailleurs s'ils le souhaitent
si c'est un choix mais c'était une
contrainte sinon sentiment qu'on les met
dehors c'est un super mais il ya quand
même aussi des gens qui partent par
choix parce qu'elle ne supporte pas
paris oui mais alors ça c'est quand même
et pas à vos simagrées maire se dit ya
un problème au centre d'une ville que
les gens n'ont plus que j'appelle fut la
dureté
parce qu'en fait la ville est devenue
irrespirable à cause de la pollution les
banques l'audit des enfants parce que le
logement est trop cher parce que les
services publics ne sont pas au niveau
je sais pas si vous prenez la ligne 13
le matin mais je vous lever très tôt je
crois pour faire des revues de presse
sur des radios mais je c'est
insupportable on est littéralement
coincée et ça c'est le quotidien des
parisiens et peu de jours en parle alors
de votre quotidien des parisiens ce sont
vous gaver a évoqué et trottinettes
électriques
qu'est ce que vous proposez aujourd'hui
la spyder par rapport à cette routine
est c'est le numéro 1 des parisiens et
des parisiennes je sais pas si le
problème numéro 1 des parisiens on parle
tout le temps à chaque fois je suis un
appartement je m'attends à parler de
logements
nous avons dit non mais les trottinettes
monsieur grand air c'est un support
gardisme en a vu un moratoire
moi je vais proposer d'ailleurs je veux
un moratoire sur les trottinettes
électriques photo ce qui avait ramassé
les mettre aux en combi je pense qu'il
faut se faire respecter
qui sont ces gens qui colonise nos
trottoirs qui déposent tous les matins
elle il joue soeur qui pose tout dépose
tous les matins des trottinettes en
pagaille sur les trottoirs et qui après
10 au parisien servez-vous et il est
parisien et bailly lui dit qu'il se
passe qu'ils auraient tort de se priver
mais ce sont les opérateurs qui ne
respectent pas l'espace public moi je
pense que quand on est maire de paris il
faut se faire respecter et on doit
défendre les parisiens or aujourd'hui il
ya les gens qui se sont percutées sur
les trottoirs ou alors qu'ils trébuchent
parce qu'ils essaient de passer en
fauteuil roulant avec une canne ont une
poussette sur un amoncellement de
trottinettes qui quand ils sont pas
balancé dans la seine on a vu ça ce
week-end s'entassent sur les trottoirs
c'est hideux en plus moi quand je suis
de triomphe récemment il y avait des
trottinettes en paille avenue de la
grande-armée 11e et de la plus belle
ville du monde ne peut pas être aussi
moche avec ces outils qui sont quand
même une laideur à trèbes et qui en plus
ne sont pas écologiquement intéressant
parce que leur obsolescence est très
rapide
et puis en plus elles sont produits avec
des batteries qui honnêtement sont très
polluantes l'autre problème on l'a un
peu évoquée mais j'ai pas tellement
compris ce que vous proposez sur ça
c'est l'insécurité
oui on en a parlé de raffinement et la
police municipale
là on a donc on connaît votre point de
vue sur la police municipale là vous
êtes d'accord avec anne hidalgo sur un
parquet les deux enfin elle c'est plus
récent qu'elle est favorable à la police
municipale puisqu'elle a été très très
bien que la police municipale c'est le
seul moyen de lutter contre l'insécurité
c'est un sujet essentiel mais je pense
que ce n'est pas le seul
il ya déjà de la vidéoprotection dans
l'espace public je pense pas qu'il soit
nécessaire d'en rajouter en revanche
dans les transports publics je pense
qu'on va faire un effort supplémentaire
de présence physique des agents mais
aussi peut-être de vérifier à ce que les
gens ne sont pas seuls dans les couloirs
qu'on puisse surveiller ses coûts voire
davantage je pense aussi qu'ils au delà
des moyens des moyens humains qui fait
une meilleure coordination entre tous
les services concernés parce que parfois
chez les dingues quand il ya aussi des
gens qui sont tout simplement malade
quand vous êtes consommateur de craquer
complètement accro au crack
on a beau vous mettre en prison vous
êtes vous arrêter toute façon vous
restez valladon fo aussi meilleure
coordination avec les services sociaux
les services sanitaires
il faut pas confondre les gens qui sont
à la rue qui n'ont pas forcément de
choix avec des délinquantes la
délinquance existe mais il faut savoir
problèmes de les traiter les problèmes
dans la globalité je pense juste un
exemple les dernières ont
a dit qu'on allait démanteler enfin
l'état et la ville ont dit qu'ils
allaient démentez la colline du crack
les portes de la chapelle un endroit
totalement indigne de notre république
dont la vider la colline 24 heures plus
tard toulon était revenu parce qu'en
fait les solutions de court terme qui
consiste juste à vider les gens avec la
police si on trouve pas de solutions de
prise en charge sanitaire et sociale
alliant nos règles pas les problèmes
durablement à propos de la porte de la
chapelle par jean-paul juste une
question mais également sur le long du
palais boulevard périphérique c'est un
autre sujet qu'est ce que vous proposez
pour justement le problème migratoire
qui est posée dans ces quartiers-là la
ville ne doit pas ne doit pas faire
croire ou tenter de faire croire qu'elle
peut régler la question des migrations
internationales tout seul ça repose sur
les épaules de l'union européenne de
l'état principalement et puis après
larry la ville et la région qui doivent
être posées de faire pression sur l'état
pour qu'il fasse le job et après la
ville a une part très particulière à
prendre en compte qui est vraiment
essentiel c'est la question des enfants
parce que les enfants
les mineurs isolés comme on les appelle
ils sont placés sous la responsabilité
du département de paris est là la ville
a le devoir ils sont plusieurs centaines
la ville a le devoir de les prendre
individuellement % changer ça c'est la
part de la ville après elle peut agir
avec les associations mais elle n'ose la
ville ne doit pas se prendre pour l'état
et c'est l'état qui doit régler le
problème
dakar est ce que anne hidalgo a eu tort
de dire que paris était une ville
ouverte aux réfugiés
on peut jamais en vouloir aux gens
d'être d'être généreux mais je pense
qu'on se demande aujourd'hui elle dit la
même chose que nous elle se tourner vers
l'état oui mais je pense qu'au départ
c'est un peu comme la grenouille qui
veut se faire aussi grosse que le boeuf
sur le sujet au migratoires et elle a eu
tort parce qu'en réalité la vie ne peut
pas régler ce problème seule elle doit
le faire avec l'état et la région c'est
ce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui la seconde
année prochaine vous serez les maires de
paris qui accueillera les jeux
olympiques en 2000 24e je vous donner un
scoop ou yvette tour je suis pour les
verts sont vrais et vous savez qui est
un truc formidable aux jo-2000 24 c'est
que le marathon des jo de 2024 sera
ouvert à tout le monde vous pouvez le
courir si vous voulez vous aussi vous
aussi et ben moi je veux courir à tous
et maire de paris jean rouvray le
marathon de paris
ce qu'on sait c'est que si on ne court
pas le marathon on pourra pas reprendre
que cdg express ce train très rapide
entre gare de l'est et l'aéroport
charles de gaulle ne sera pas mis en
service pour 2024
c'est un regret il faut déplorer passons
maintenant ça sert à rien de pleurer sur
le lait renversé je pense que ça a été
mal conduit parce qu'on n'avait pas
pensé
du monde de comparable à paris n'a pas
toutes les bêtes ont peur du monde
comparé à paris ont un système
d'aéroport au centre-ville rapide fiable
alors je vous dire quelque chose je
pense qu'à court terme c'est dommage de
surtout on avait pris l'engagement de
créer mais à long terme soyons lucides
le transport aérien est pas l'avenir des
transports de notre humanité
lee perry filières non mais un héros
porsche propose pas de décrue à
l'aéroport mais je vous dis qu'on fait
dans l'échelle des problèmes que l'on a
est traitée finalement rétablir le cdg
express n'est pas la priorité numéro un
reste que lors de votre campagne qui a
commencé comme vous lancer sur ce
plateau on va le dire si on veut dire
qu'il y aura un avant et un après voilà
très bien vous avez tout compris
est-ce que lors de votre campagne qui
commence véritablement ce soir gaspard
granser françois hollande montrera plus
d'allant qu'avec raf et le luxe man j'en
doute par jour d'eau depuis ce qu'on
fait mais je crois qu'il ya je crois que
vous a pas encourager aux dernières
nouvelles il était plutôt pour soupire
anne hidalgo bonne façon de françois
hollande il est socialiste donc c'est
normal il va voter pour la candidate
socialiste qui annule et peut-être qui
vous a donné ce virus de la politique
si je veux dire ce qu'il veut pas
renoncer renoncera jamais à lui alors
oui oui mais les salles us être il ya
quelque chose que j'ai retenu de lui
c'est qu'il aime les gens et qu'ils
adorent discuter avec eux et moi tous
les soirs sélection les appartements des
bars des cafés à discuter avec les gens
et souvent je pense à l'actuel hollande
qui a passé sa vie à faire ça avec lui a
fait plus plaisir de le faire mme baka
la corvée qu'est ce que vous lui
conseiller en termes de communication
aujourd'hui certains disent il doit se
taire je pense que la situation est
tellement confuse qu'il faut mieux pour
l'instant dhr laisser les choses de
retomber tranquillement plus j'ai été un
peu étonné parce que les socialistes
avaient l'air assez contents de leur
score aux positions européennes parce
que je pense qu'il ya eu tellement peur
de faire sachant que le fait de faire
six ou sept s'étaient hissés en cendres
par seconde a évidemment on peut se
jouer la victoire mais même ça reste
quand même très faible c'est ça restait
la social-démocratie asco basse et oui
c'est terrible
c'est fondamental je pense que pour
l'instant il a raison d'analyser la
situation et puis après sa voix comptera
toujours dans la reconstruction de la
gauche
donc il s'exprimera après votre
voudra-t-il dû jouer un rôle actif ça ça
lui appartient
moi je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit
autour de la social démocratie
traditionnelle que la gauche pourra se
reconstruire mais plutôt à mon avis
autour de l'écologie
les sondages donnent aller au maximum 7
% aujourd'hui
mais je faisais cette autre et ça je
trouve que c'est sympa travailler plus
pour encourager
alors donc la question c'était de savoir
quelle force d'appoint jusqu'à demain
pour qui est ce que quand même malgré
tout on comprend que vous défendez votre
candidature avec des lignes fortes comme
la suppression du périphérique qu'elle
en a du mal il est quand même le dire
croit on sera d'accord avec moi
est ce que répètent une force d'appoint
et ses très proches je me suis pas lancé
non ça pourrait être la russie ou la
jambe de bois de quiconque on ira
jusqu'au bout et vous verrez on gagnera
raglan on va vous suivre donc
attentivement vous et les autres
jasper grazer merci merci à vous d'être
venu ce soir merci messieurs bonsoir à
tous et à très vite
[Musique]